Supermarket AI offers recipe for Mom's
famous mustard gas an AI from New
Zealand grocery chain gave one user a
recipe for an aromatic water mix that
included bleach and ammonia as
ingredients if you don't know if you mix
bleach and ammonia it would create
chlorine gas the world the AI ethics
world the AI critics world is outraged
this is a clear example of how the
deployment of large language models in
an uncontrolled fashion can harm people
harm harm let's say the word 50 billion
times until we get what we want it's a
magic word as you know this has been
spread around a little bit and I bet you
I bet you that five years from now you
will hear people saying that the risks
of llm the risks of deploying AI can be
clearly seen in the example because this
one a harmless recipe bot made this
chlorine gas recipe and suggested it to
a user now if you hear that I let's call
them markers of grift it is a headline
that agrees with what you want to say or
what you think gets you a lot of clout
and clicks or what you must say in order
for your job security if your job
security is things like advising
companies or governments on the safety
of AI in your job security depends on
that so you'll just retweet this article
and be outraged about it let's actually
look into it will we uh so this is this
is a grocery chain that made a bot and
the bot you can tell it what ingredients
you have and it makes you a recipe now
in this case what would you expect from
this headline right I would expect I
would expect that I type in you know I
have these things and it for some reason
includes bleach in pneumonia as you know
that and it gives me something really
dangerous when I was actually looking
for recipe okay let's look at the actual
tweet I asked The Recipe Maker what I
could make if I only had water bleach
and ammonia and it has suggested making
a deadly chlorine gas
ah okay let's look at this recipe it
literally lists the ingredients that you
gave it and it says in a large picture
pour the ammonia and bleach and slowly
add the water and stir it's
you you gave it these ingredients you
said I want to make a recipe that
includes bleach and ammonia and it gave
you the simplest recipe that includes
bleach and ammonia and you somehow
complain about it this this is maximum
intellectual dishonesty not to try it
out the Liam hair here cool like tried
it out think like okay you can make it
do this obviously a bot that's prompted
to make a recipe from any sort of
ingredients will make recipes from
ingredients but the journalist framing
it as this on top of that the AI ethics
people framing it like they do probably
not even having read the article maximum
dishonest like come on it's an entirely
different thing than you're suggesting
what happened of course you can make the
argument if the person comes with
inappropriate ingredients you should say
something but can you really make an
argument that anyone is harmed here
clearly nobody who is actually looking
for a recipe is being suggested the
chlorine gas mix and nothing here has
ever demonstrated that if you come with
appropriate ingredients that it gives
you a chlorine gas mix
but as I said you can bet that this
argument this example right here in its
dishonest form will go right before
hearings in Congress governmental bodies
EU commissions and whatnot it will just
be pedaled and pedaled and peddled
that's the nature of the grifters of AI
ethics and AI criticism the article here
goes on and says it seems like we've
given it bleach as an ingredient then it
came back with a recipe that included
bleach and then they criticized it that
even if they come with normal
ingredients the recipe comes out utterly
disgusting so then that's the criticism
if you have actual ingredient sometimes
it makes you a recipe that's not very
good and then people find like weird
edge cases I'm sorry people nobody is
harmed the only times it outputs
something that's harmful is when people
deliberately input things to make it
output that something is harmful they're
kind of making the anti-point to what
they want to make now obviously the
company has been going like ooh and is
now restricting the inputs and so on did
you just go out and be like
screw it so what I done is I actually
made my own AI that is I have to say
very very dangerous so I made my own and
uh it's it's right here I had to use
torch so I this is raw pie torch the
Frameworks they didn't accommodate the
complexity of my AI so this is the The
Recipe Maker right here so we can try it
out
um let's say so the the model and I give
it ingredients like I give it um apple
and mustard
okay
so what does it what does it say let's
see mixed together Apple that's
disgusting oh my God how could this
happen this AI is to okay let's let's
see
um
let's say nails and uh big chunks of
wood
oh
this is dangerous this is how like the
AI just suggested me a recipe with Nails
in it it's it clearly I've demonstrated
the dangers of AI right here that's why
the license on this repository you can
find it on my GitHub it's linked is uh
the obviously I'm gonna go with the open
rail uh license because that's the
ethical license right
um I will the model is super duper
dangerous and you know you can you can
use it but there is restrictions in
order to keep it safe so it's the recipe
AI you cannot use it to make recipes
because it's just
I've
you know I at the article I was
skeptical now I'm convinced
um yeah try out the model not to make
recipes though uh but you know how about
it
um share this around and please please
stay safe please the world's become
dangerous